what if the actor is more in tune with
the script than the director or do you
not often see that you see that the
director is pre honed in on the script
of the beats of it the characters well
it's it's interesting it's a it's a
great question because it's that
imbalance of not only understanding the
script but being in tuned with this
script is a big problem yeah there are a
lot of directors who believe they know
the script well and we can talk about
writer directors too and sometimes just
because they've written it they believe
they know the characters very deeply
profoundly sometimes they do often they
don't there are some actors who when
working on a script it will become very
in tuned with a character very very
quickly and very very deeply and it
again it depends on the actor and how
the actors work some actors work on a
very superficial level some work on a
very deep level the the real challenge
is to take everybody to a deep level
directors and actors and the characters
to the deepest level possible and not to
settle for something that's more
superficial or to be intimidated by the
other actors can be intimidated by a
director who seems to know so much about
the character that the actor gets gets
frightened this is part of the fear of
some of the feeling oh he knows the
character so well oh my god you know
what am i you know suddenly they feel
intimidated or very often directors who
feel intimidated by actors because
especially really good actors what one
problem that some directors can have
with really good actors his problem is
is casting really good actors seriously
is a really good actor can give you
almost anything and then you go now what
do I do in other words a director corner
how about if we play it this way you
know have this kind of woman and the
actor does he wow that's great
and I will say to the director fine what
do you want and the director doesn't
know I said well now you got a problem
you have with the riches of talent in
front of you and you don't know where
you're going in other words you don't
know the script
if you don't know the scene well enough
you don't know the characters well
enough you don't know your story well
enough to be directing and this is again
why a lot of directors shy away from the
actors and I've heard directors say you
know if I cast it well I'm fine
why do I need to do other pygar but
these are really good actors they'll
build they'll do it I'm working with one
director now who's directing he's a good
director but his directing is minimal
and he tells me what every scene he shot
it's a movie that's shooting now it's an
independent film and I've seen something
seen he every scene I say I say okay how
did it go
great they nailed it as soon as I hear
that I know we got a problem because
he's saying that for every is either
they nailed it or they hit it out of the
park every scene and I got I can't be
true that can't be true and nothing I'm
not doing a good job I'm sure they're
doing a good job between I doing the
best job but his assessment of their
performance I think it's always if it's
highly emotional and intense and they
give a lot of energy to it then it's
fine
so he does I don't think he and he wrote
the script I don't think he knows the
characters well enough so is that why a
director would be afraid of an actor
there they're afraid of being exposed as
a fraud so to speak it seems I've heard
this for years that actors are seeing
that directors are so afraid of actors I
could see the reverse it's intimidating
they hold all this power they have the
decision to cut you out of scenes
whatever but in the reverse it just
seems so perplexing to me why directors
are afraid of actors right I'll give you
one reason I think and and quite
honestly Kara night sometimes I bring
this up in front of directors to sit
with their responses but really God
worked with a lot of really good
directors and a lot of really good
directors are very knowledgeable about
film filmmaking the technology the
cameras the lights the sounds digital
place a replacement CGI all the
equipment and we're going to shoot this
with a Steadicam we're gonna do all you
know and it's amazing what they know and
it's amazing what they can do and it's
amazing how they can visualize the film
and all that and I'm just I'm impressed
that's not that's not my area of
strength and then they come these same
directors will come to an actor and
suddenly they're shaky and I think I
know why if I was working with a crew
and I were talking about cameras and
lights and angles
that's very manageable equipment i can
understand that i can understand framing
i can understand i can see immediately
am i getting what I want
am I getting what I want and production
designer because I'm dealing with
something that's tangible working with
actress there's nothing tangible I'm
working with an emotional system a pool
of emotions inside a character and I
don't know how to manage that I don't
know what I want really I can't define
what I want I can't tell that person put
a different lens on it and it'll work I
can tell you that to the camera you know
no not a 50 we're gonna go to a 35 it'll
look better I can do that I can't say so
every all the other directing that I do
with everybody else on the crew it's all
result give me this result I wanted a
different color blue I want this to be
bigger I want this to be smaller I
wanted to shoot outside one it's I can't
I can results and everybody can give me
a results I can't talk that great to an
actor because it won't work I can't say
I need more vulnerability because it
won't work in other words I'm dealing
with a human being and I don't have the
tools and the techniques to know how to
handle that and the sad thing is I'm
working with these actors and at the
center of my thirty million dollar movie
the only thing is going to make it work
is the actors the rest of it won't make
the movie work or this can bring it down
if the performances aren't good if
they're not strong if it's not powerful
it's not telling the story I want to
tell it so that's the most important
part of my movie and that's my weakest
place so I think the fear is because I
have to talk to actors on more of a
psychological level where I can talk
with everybody else on a more mechanical
level so it's where they're almost
afraid of their lack of emotional
intelligence in some sense I mean they
know technical things how you mean
they're emotionally no you mean the
directors
afraid of actors of their emotional
intelligence or actually of the
directors afraid of their own lack of
emotional intelligence afraid of their
lack of knowledge of what that person
does and how do I talk to that person -
there's another big problem how do I
talk to that person to get them to do
what I think they should do in this
scene the way I imagine it when I read
it because I think that'll work did you
understand right and and I mean an
intelligent director will know that the
way he here's the scene he or she hasn't
seen when they read it is maybe not the
best way for it to play but how do i
guide the actor through either a
rehearsal process or while we're
shooting to explore a range of possible
emotional moments out of which I can
make a really good scene how do I do
that I mean it's a mystery and it's and
it's very different so I think the a lot
of directors will just shoot a lot okay
let's do it again
what do you want I just did it again I
need I heard this on the set the other
day a long time ago I need more bigger
emotions this time and the asset you
know now the actors do it they did it
louder that's all they did
bigger emotions and you know I need I
need more vulnerability and and I my
heart goes out to directors like I see
him fighting to find the language with
which to deal with a human being which
is giving them a genuine emotional
performance and how do you modify that
it's easier to say okay now that no no
shadows are too sharp I need it darker I
mean or wolf will fix that in color
correction okay that's easy I can't I
can't adjust an actor's performance in
post-production I can't do that and so
it's it's the fact that that part of
directing is all psychology it's not
technical at all and they try to make it
technical
you